[Música]
ah
y
[Música]
quiero que me vean y que se pregunten
que creen que soy
vamos por lo obvio soy mujer y soy
adolescente pero quizás no se han dado
cuenta que también soy programadora
la sociedad como un conjunto de personas
que se relacionan de alguna u otra forma
nos hacen encajar a cada uno en
etiquetas
los etiquetamos y nos etiquetan para
poder definir qué somos entender qué rol
cumplimos o queremos cumplir nuestro
dentro de esta sociedad
pero por qué fue tan obvio decir que soy
mujer y que soy adolescente pero no que
soy programadora
en la programación también hay etiquetas
de la misma manera que en la sociedad y
etiquetas para poder diferenciar lo
distinto entender las cosas de manera
general -sin casi darlas en un orden en
la programación utilizamos etiquetas
pero mediante código para que lo que vea
una persona a través de una pantalla es
entendible
imaginemos esto
acá
tenemos un perfil de 'facebook' todo lo
que vemos está acomodado mediante
etiquetas tenemos una foto una barra de
notificaciones la cantidad de amigos que
tenés conectados todo esto a cómodo
mediante etiquetas
fue acomodado de uno en un orden
específico esas etiquetas fueron
utilizadas en un lugar correcto para que
muestre una información correcta y que
si la cambiáramos del lugar
probablemente nos mostraría algo que nos
incomodar y a la vista o que
directamente no funcionaría
correctamente
imagínense por un programador ver esto
creo que no solamente un programador
sino también a todos veo algo así con el
traje a facebook debe ser realmente
incómodo pero para los programadores
sería aún más por no decir otras cosas
sería como si te entra dejado en los
ojos por ejemplo pero por qué por qué se
genera tanta incomodidad
porque ellos saben que las etiquetas
están siendo utilizadas incorrectamente
saben que las etiquetas están fuera de
su lugar
y de la manera me sentido yo como una
etiqueta fuera de lugar cada vez que
digo programadora y que soy programadora
y que se no se ha tomado como algo tan
natural
de hecho lo busqué en internet al perfil
de un programador y los resultados de
las imágenes de google me mostró esto
al parecer ser programador significa ser
una persona de gran intelecto y poca
vida social y también tener problemas de
miopía porque todos usan anteojos
y pasarse todo el día programando pero
además en esta imagen hay algo que se
tienen que dar cuenta porque si no
estamos en problemas
muy bien todos son hombres
al parecer el perfil de un programador
es los hombres sin embargo esto está muy
alejado de la realidad de lo que en
verdad somos los programadores no solo
los hombres pueden programar y no solo
las personas que se pasan las 24 horas
del día los 7 días de la semana
programando pueden hacerlo todos podemos
hacerlo
pero esta idea de programador viene
también del firme pensamiento que se
tiene sobre lo que es la programación
que considerado como una rama de las
ciencias duras que es difícil de
comprender y de manejar y que solo las
personas que tienen gran intelecto
pueden hacerlo
de todas maneras si podemos cuestionar
todas estas etiquetas que hay sobre los
programadores porque nos cuestionamos
también de dónde proviene esto
tratemos de poner la programación en un
lugar que se encaje que pasa si vamos a
la programación como un arte por ejemplo
es cierto que la programación se debe
tener un conocimiento previo de lo que
se está haciendo para poder llevar a
cabo una idea aquellos que programan por
trabajo o por hobby necesitaron
aprenderlo de alguna forma pero esto no
sucede de la noche a la mañana surgen
dificultades obviamente que si de la
propia experiencia pueda decir que
muchas veces te da dolor de cabeza
cuando intentas correr un programa es
decir fijarte si anda y no anda
pero el jubile error
es algo muy común entre los
programadores así aprendemos la mayoría
de nosotros
y también de la misma forma sucede en el
arte porque aunque los artistas se les
asocia una mentalidad menos lógica y más
emocional una obra de arte no se realiza
la primera ni mucho menos se hace de la
noche a la mañana
pero porque también pasaron por un
proceso creativo que los ayudo a través
del intento de este juego y error poder
llevar a cabo su obra
esto también sucede en la programación
en aplicaciones que nosotros utilizamos
diariamente por detrás un grupo de
programadores que se plantearon una idea
o algún cuestionamiento y buscaron
llevar a cabo una solución mediante
código porque hoy en día gracias a los
avances tecnológicos podemos programar
casi cualquier cosa
es decir detrás de todas las
aplicaciones que nosotros utilizamos hay
un porqué y un para que que luego se ve
reflejado en la manera en que nosotros
entendemos las cosas y según el uso que
le demos tomamos otra percepción esto
también pasa en el arte porque las obras
de arte tienen la capacidad de crear
nuevos mundos y también mostrar unos
puntos de vista de nuevos puntos de
vista del nuestro y de esa manera
también tomamos percepción otra
percepción de las cosas además que de
alguna u otra forma en la programación
te permite concretar todo estos dos esos
mundos que el arte te provee
además está el lenguaje de otras
semejanzas
si nosotros vemos esto
esto
podemos ver que todas estas imágenes
representan distintos tipos de artes
pero si las analizamos nos vamos a dar
cuenta que todas estas fueron creadas a
través de lenguajes distintos entonces
porque no podemos pensar
porque no podemos pensar que acá se está
utilizando el lenguaje artístico por el
simple hecho de que se está utilizando
un lenguaje distinto
alguien me puede decir
arte programación lenguaje proceso
creativo juego y error alguna resaca
algunos lo piensas de hecho yo cuando lo
estaba pensando con un grupo de amigos y
estábamos charlando sobre este
cuestionamiento que me estoy haciendo de
las cosas de esto un compañero que para
mantenerlo en el anonimato le vamos a
decir z me dijo algo que me voló la
cabeza 7 me dijo vos pensás todas estas
cosas artísticas porque es muy típico de
las mujeres
que es típico de las mujeres
las carreras artísticas son típicas de
las mujeres y eso hace la programación
algo típico de los hombres
lamentablemente pareciera ser que sí
de hecho en la noria de egresos en la
universidad nacional de córdoba mostró
que en la carrera de licenciatura de
ciencias de la computación
hubo una cantidad de egresados de 27
estudiantes
saben cuántas mujeres hubo entre estos
27 estudiantes
una
una mujer entre 27 egresados
esa mujer esa etiqueta fuera del lugar
es el reflejo de cómo nos cuesta a
nosotras las mujeres vernos en un lugar
al que no nos etiquetaron
nos enseñaron y asumimos de chicas desde
siempre que las mujeres somos mucho más
emocionales que los hombres y no
casualmente a los artistas también se
les asocia a esa persona esa
personalidad emocional y sentimental
entonces porque no podemos pensar que
acá está el porqué de no poder ver a la
programación como un arte
la programación y el arte no suena raro
porque no tienen nada en común porque de
hecho si lo tienen lo acabamos de ver
que creamos que son dos campos de
conocimiento de distintos que no se
tienen que juntar de ninguna forma es
una mera construcción social porque las
etiquetas que conllevan estos muestran
que fueron creadas para géneros
distintos
y de la propia experiencia quiero
mostrar que no sólo las mujeres podemos
programar y que nuestra capacidad no se
tiene que ver cuestionada porque este
pensamiento lógico se le asocia los
hombres
no dijimos que la sociedad nos programe
para hacer lo que otros pensaron por
nosotros programa la voz a ella para que
cuando hablemos de etiquetas podamos
usarlo como una forma de expresar cuán
orgullosos nos sentimos de lo que somos
y no de lo que te limita porque la
sociedad espera que seas muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]